Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of
the Decent. I'm your host as always Ricardo Lops
. And today I'm joined by Doctor Paul Halpern.
He is Professor of Physics at Saint Joseph's University in
Philadelphia. He is the author of several books.
And today we're focusing on his latest one, the
Allure of the Multiverse, extra dimensions, other worlds
and parallel universes. So Paul, welcome to the
show. It's a big pleasure to everyone. My
pleasure to thank you for having me on your show
, Ricardo. So let's start with this then.
Uh I know that in the book, you go
through a little bit actually of the history behind the
idea of the multiverse and the UX you of of
course, focus mostly on physics, but you also
talk about the ideas of some philosophers, for example
. So do you know how old is the idea
of the multiverse actually? Well, it's interesting because
the term multiverse goes back to William James who was
a, a writer and uh and also kind of
an early psychologist. And uh he talked about the
psychological idea of a multiverse back in the 19th century
uh as kind of a morally ambiguous universe, that
a universe that was neither good nor evil and was
pretty much ambivalent to whether someone is good, someone
is evil. So he called it kind of a
moral multiverse. But that's just a term. I
don't think he meant that in the sense of parallel
universes and the idea of parallel universes and science really
took off in the 19 seventies and 19 eighties and
especially in this century, in the 21st century,
the idea really became popular but going all the way
back to the people like Giordano, Bruno, uh
you know, the Italian uh philosopher, that's when
people start talking about many worlds out there, worlds
that might be similar to earth. And Bruno,
of course, famously was burned at the stake for
writing that there are an infinite number of worlds out
there. And some of those could be, you
know, inhabited and like earth. And he speculated
about this and that was considered uh heresy blasphemy by
the Roman inquisition. And, you know, sadly
, he was killed by the Roman inquisition for,
for that heresy and other heresies. And then around
the same time, Galileo, who was a little
bit higher placed, he had more connections. So
he wasn't uh luckily he wasn't executed, but he
also speculated about, you know, many worlds out
there. And then in the 19th century, based
upon Newtonian physics, Newtonian determinism, uh people start
figuring out that if you have a finite number of
elements a finite number of possibilities. But an infinite
universe eventually all the combinations would start to repeat themselves
. So just like if you're playing uh the game
of chess, eventually you run out of moves and
would repeat the same moves. They're not an infinite
number of moves in chess. Similarly, uh if
you had an infinite universe, but a finite number
of elements and a finite number of possibilities, eventually
, you would have something like Earth recreated and the
philosopher, while the the revolutionary uh Luis Blanc Blanche
in France, while he was imprisoned in a fortress
for revolutionary activity, speculated that there might be um
many, many copies of Earth out there that some
of them might be exact, some of them might
be inexact. And maybe some of the things that
play out on Earth would happen in some of the
other universes such as, you know, French revolution
and so forth. So it's kind of interesting to
think about this. But now we know that the
universe is expanding and accelerating its expansion. So and
it might be that there is a duplicate Earth out
there, but it would be so far away from
us will be well beyond the possibility of observation,
well beyond the observable universe, because the sheer probability
of creating uh something that's exactly like the Earth would
be so minimal that it would take far longer than
the than the time length of the Big Bang and
far greater than the size of the observable universe to
recreate something like that. So it's, it's pretty
much impossible. So one idea that you mentioned there
, the fact that people at a certain point notice
that if there are a limited number of possible arrangements
of matter, then if time is infinite, then
eventually the same configurations would repeat themselves over time.
That's actually something that comes around also in Nietzsche,
right? And the idea of the eternal return because
I, I guess that in that aspect, he
was influenced by some uh physicists back in the 19th
century, right? Yeah. So Friedrich Nietzsche,
the German philosopher um came up with the idea of
eternal return. And uh he unlike uh Eastern philosophers
, he talked about an exact repetition of history.
Um So he imagined that his life and all of
its pain and suffering and some joy, mostly a
little bit of joy would um repeat itself sometime in
the future just based upon the idea of chance reoccurrence
. So, you know, for any kind of
game with finite elements, I mentioned chess, but
also the game of tiktok Toe with Xs and Os
. Eventually you just run out of moves. And
Tik Tok Toe, if you're familiar with it has
a square, has nine uh elements in a square
with Xs and Os is the only possibilities. And
it's, it could be a boring game if you
play it long enough because you repeat the same moves
again and again. And similarly, Nietzsche thought that
his life will repeat itself. But if we estimate
how long it would take for earth to repeat itself
, uh It was, you know, far,
far, far, you know, almost unimaginably far
longer than the history of the universe. So it's
, it's incredibly unlikely as people like uh Nietzsche's contemporary
Ludwig Boltzmann pointed out Boltzmann talked about the idea of
the arrow of time and increasing entropy. People said
, hey, wait a minute, things could randomly
come together again. But the estimate of that happening
, it's just incredibly improbable. So uh normally we
don't have to worry about it. Mhm But uh
let me just ask you one question since you mentioned
Giordano Bruno there earlier and also Galileo and I,
we're talking about Nietzsche because if I understand it correctly
, uh For example, Giordano Bruno was uh talking
back then in the 16 century or so about there
being other worlds. But by worlds, I guess
he was referring mostly to planets, other planets like
earth out there, I mean, but so uh
and if those people are mostly talking about uh other
worlds in our universe or in the case of Nietzsche
inside of our universe, things repeating themselves over time
. Uh That isn't exactly the same thing as a
multiverse. Yeah, that is an excellent point.
And that's why I say the modern idea of a
multiverse, actual multiverse started in really in the 19
seventies when you had Bryce de Witt popularizing the idea
of Hugh Everett of um what's called the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics. And that's a name that
Dewitt uh almost coined. He said many universes,
but it became many worlds. And then Brandon Carter
took that idea and turned it into the, you
know, variation of it into the anthropic principle.
And then later, other scientists took that idea to
try to explain fine tuning and I'm sure we'll talk
about that later. But that was an actual idea
of something beyond the physical universe. But, you
know, our scope has expanded over the centuries.
So of course, um in a time of Pythagoras
, the time of the ancient Greeks, no one
imagined that there was really anything beyond earth. And
maybe the, you know, the Pythagorean talked about
a central fire, but they talked about 10 objects
including the celestial sphere, which was, you know
, this the dome of stars and that was kind
of considered something fixed out there, not something with
, you know, unlimited objects, but something that
was just kind of this fixed dome, fixed uh
element. And um you know, these planets,
but we had no idea what the scope of the
the galaxy was, let alone the universe. And
then of course, in the time of Galileo and
Bruno, we started to think about um other stars
, other planets uh but they weren't known yet and
it was only in the 19 nineties, believe it
or not that um astronomers detected the first exoplanets beyond
the solar system. And that was, you know
, when we got to confirm that hypothesis, finally
, Bruno hypothesis that there are actually other planets around
other stars. And now most astronomers think that there
are trillions of planets out there. You know,
just based upon the ones we've found so far,
the thousands of ones we've found so far, if
you extrapolate, there are likely planets around most stars
. So we can talk about trillions of planets out
there. But then within, you know, within
the last 100 years, believe it or not.
Um That's when we discovered other Galaxies. It was
only really in 1926 with the observations of Edwin Hubble
that we showed that the Andromeda nebula as it was
called, it was thought to be a gas cloud
was really an object outside of, of our own
own galaxy. And that resolved what was called the
great debate over whether or not the milky way was
the only object give or take a few things in
the periphery or if there are numerous Galaxies out there
. And how do physicists themselves uh think about the
multiverse? And are there different conceptualizations of what the
multiverse might be among physicists? Yeah. So there
are many different multiverses which can be a little bit
confusing and none of them are really like the cultural
idea of the multiverse, which you can also talk
about, which is the multiverse in movies. So
everyone imagines in movies, you know, you wake
up and you, you go through a portal and
you see a near identical version of yourself or you
see, you know, a, a superhero that
has a different origin story, like a different Spiderman
or different, you know, different version of ultra
or whatever, like different superheroes. But uh you
know, in, in physics, the multiverse ideas
are confined to either something having to do with the
very small or something having to do with the very
large. So either quantum multiverse or a cosmological multiverse
. And the quantum multiverse is usually called the many
worlds interpretation of quantum mechanics. And that was developed
by Hugh Everett the third who was a student of
the great American physicist John Wheeler, who I who
I had the pleasure of meeting before he passed away
, very interesting fellow. And whoever it proposed the
idea that when you take a quantum measurement, you
the observer do not affect the measurement, uh you
do not influence the measurement. So then the question
arises, how come you get an exact result?
Whereas we know in quantum physics, you have a
blending of possibilities before the measurement is taken. How
do you get an exact result when the measurement was
taken? And the old idea, the orthodox idea
is that the measurer collapses the wave function down to
one possibility like knocking over a a stack of of
cards and collapsing it down to a single pile.
Well Everett's idea is that the measurer does not affect
anything. Rather the measurer sees all the possibilities,
all the the different outcomes at once. Well,
how can that happen? Because the measurers conscious uh
conscious record says, I see one observation. So
that must mean that the measures consciousness branches out into
multiple possibilities. And each version of the conscious observer
sees a different value or a different outcome of the
measurement. So there's a branching of human beings that
matches the branching of quantum outcomes and that all matches
up with a universal wave function that never collapses.
But there's all these possibilities out there in different enclaves
of the universe. So that gives you parallel universes
. So that's a quantum idea and cosmology. It's
the possibility of other bubble universes out there aside from
the Big Bang. So aside from uh our own
Big Bang, that there are other universes expanding out
there just beyond the range of observation. And that
for some people is more palatable because that's not something
that's happening all the time. This is something that
um happens, you know, with a cosmogenesis event
, a uni universe creation event. And it almost
seems in a way logical if our universe is created
in a in a relatively easy way through um you
know, the observable universe created in a process called
inflation that maybe inflation happens, you know, elsewhere
in in reality. And so those are the main
reasons uh why the theoretical physicists have theorized about the
possible multiverse is I, is it for with,
with the idea of explaining those aspects of our reality
? Yes. Well, we want to explain the
observable universe and we want to explain the observable results
from quantum measurements. So we know that when we
take a quantum measurement, we get um if we
repeat the measurement, we, we might get different
outcomes. But we can, if we repeat the
measurement enough times, we can map out the probabilities
of those various outcomes. So we know that there's
a certain amount of chance, we know that there's
a certain range of possibilities. We know that we
don't always get the same possibility. And we know
that um that the uh results uh can only be
precise for certain parameters that we, because of Eise
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle that we can't measure position pre precisely
and the momentum precisely at the same time. So
these are things we know the question is how to
explain it. And there are many different ways to
explain quantum measurement. Uh Similarly, we know that
the universe on the largest scale is very even very
regular. If we look in one direction, we
see pretty much the same number of Galaxies as in
the complete opposite direction. If we look and measure
the cosmic radiation background, the temperature of it is
very, very close to the same in all directions
, there's slight variations. So the question is how
do we get such uniformity. Is it just a
coincidence or is there some reason that the universe smoothed
out in the beginning that led to the idea of
inflation? And then it turns out that inflation is
pretty easy to produce in Einstein's general theory of relativity
by just having the right energy configuration, the right
energy set up. So um so Andre Linday,
the Russian born um cosmologist who's now at Stanford University
, came up with the idea of an eternal inflation
, which is that this happens repeatedly. But I
should say that the idea of the multiverse really became
popular when people started grappling with the idea that the
cosmological constant of the universe, which is a anti
kind of anti gravity parameter that's causing the universe to
slightly accelerate um over time um seems very large by
one calculation, calculating the quantum energy background. So
if you look at empty space, it's not really
empty, it has particles that are popping in and
out of emptiness. And if you add up the
energy of all those particles, you get something that
could be called the cosmological constant. And let me
explain what the cosmological constant is. When Einstein developed
his general theory of relativity, which is how space
and time uh create gravity through their curvature. He
realized that he wasn't getting stable results, he was
getting results that would either contract or expand. And
it was when he developed that was, that was
before hubble's um proof as it turns out that the
universe is expanding and he thought he made a mistake
. So he added the cosmological constant as a stabilizing
term, which kind of pushes the universe outward to
stabilize it against gravity to make it a steady universe
, a static universe. But then uh he dropped
that idea. He said it was a big mistake
that he shouldn't have even introduced it. But ideas
tend to persist. And in 1998 2 teams of
cosmologists used um uh observations of the universe to show
that not only is the universe expanding, it's accelerating
in its expansion. So something is pushing it out
faster and faster over time. And that must be
something which sometimes is called dark energy. But you
could also use a cosmological constant as a way of
modeling that dark dark energy that cosmological constant turns out
to be very, very small because if it were
big, it would have affected uh the development of
stars Galaxies and so forth. It would have made
it impossible for structure to form. So it's this
really, really minute cosmological constant. So you don't
feel it until billions of years into the history of
the universe. So the 1st 5 billion years of
so the history of the universe, you don't feel
this anti gravity push and stars can form Galaxies form
earth forms, everything forms just nice. But then
later in the history of the universe, suddenly you
start feeling this outward push and the universe starts to
speed up in its expansion because this cosmological constant term
is small. But people in quantum field theory calculate
the cosmological constant based on the energy of empty space
. And they say it must be huge. So
the question is why in reality, you have a
small cosmological constant. But really based on quantum field
theory, you should have a large one. And
the answer that some people have is that maybe the
universe is really a multiverse and that you have all
these expanding universes out there. And each of them
has its own cosmological constant and that some of them
are enormous and some of them are moderate. And
we happen to be in an outlier, we happen
to be in the very, very odd strange universe
that has a tiny cosmological constant. So, um
you know, so we are just in this really
bizarre universe that has a small cosmo cosmological constant.
But it's lucky that we are because that's the only
way stars can form and Galaxies can form and life
can form. And that's why we're here because we
happen to be in a universe with a tiny cosmological
constant and all the other universes with the large cosmological
constants never formed structure. So there was no one
there to say, hey, we're in a universe
with a large cosmological constant. So you mentioned Einstein
there and of course, if theorize about the space
time continuum and about 1/4 dimension of reality. Does
this idea of going above the three dimensions also connect
in any way to the idea of the multiverse or
not? Well, the idea of dimensions is very
interesting. Uh dimensions is a little bit of a
strange concept because we know that there are three tangible
physical dimensions. You know, if we, we
can, you know, walk north and south,
we can walk east and west or we can jump
up and down. Those are the three ways we
can move. Uh So those are the physical dimensions
. But then at some point, people started saying
, even in the late 19th century, that time
has a quality that resembles a dimension. Uh because
uh you can imagine things changing over time just like
they might be different in different directions in space.
And that was idea was solidified. Uh When Herman
Mankowski in 1907 said that Einstein's special theory of relativity
was best developed in 44 dimensions. And finally,
after a few years of saying, oh dimensions,
four dimension is kind of an abstract concept and not
really liking it. Einstein adopted the fourth dimension and
used it in his general theory of relativity. So
that's pretty well accepted. But around the time that
Einstein proposed General Relativity, a phys, a mathematician
uh Theodore Kaluza who was in uh East Prussia and
part of then part of Germany, a German empire
um wrote to Einstein and said, hey, wait
a minute, maybe you can add another force to
your theory, electricity and magnetism, which we call
electromagnetism by adding an extra dimension to your theory and
having 1/5 dimension that uh we don't detect but still
comes into the theory. So that's the Kusa idea
of the fifth dimension. And later someone named Oscar
Klein connected with qua quantum physics. So now we
call that Kusa Klein um higher dimensional theory. And
Klein proposed the idea that the higher dimension was kind
of curled up into a very tight circle, kind
of like if you look at a piece of spaghetti
or a piece of pasta, and you look at
not the long part of it, but we look
at the radius of it. It's very, very
tiny. So if you were observing a piece of
spaghetti from a great distance, it would just look
like a one dimensional object, it would look like
a straight line. You wouldn't be able to tell
that it has a thickness. And similarly in the
uh Calusa Klein picture, um the higher dimension,
the fifth dimension is curled up so tightly into such
a tight little circle that we never really detect it
, that's impossible to detect. Well, um if
you look later in the history of physics, string
theory was developed starting in the 19 eighties as this
idea that particles are not really particles, but they're
energetic strands that are vibrating and their vibrations create the
particle categories. But mathematicians discovered that string theory does
not mathematically make sense. It's mathematically inconsistent unless you
put it into a 10 dimensional theory at least.
And so you need to add not just 1/5 dimension
, but you need to add six more dimensions beyond
space and time. So, uh so you have
10 dimensions. And um in a related topic called
Super Gravity, um people like Eugene Kremer and Bernard
Julia in France developed the idea of spontaneous compact application
. Um And I think that was developed in the
late 19 seventies, this idea that um all the
other dimensions would collapse and you would only see four
of the dimensions, but the other dimensions would just
, you know, become crushed into something that's undetectable
. And um other physicists found that there are many
, many, many different ways that this collapse of
the higher dimensions can occur and many different possible geometries
for the higher dimension. Once it's collapsed, it
turns out to be 10 to the 500 power possibilities
for this kind of collapse into 10 to the 500
power types of geometries. And you could think of
those geometries kind of like pretzels, not just rings
but or doughnuts, but all these different twisty pretzels
, you know, and imagine 10 with a 500
zeros possibilities. And each of these can lead to
its own universe model its own physics. And um
some physicists talk about, you know, 10 to
the 500 possible universes out there, each with its
own um type of what we call internal geometry.
Um internal meaning that you don't really see it as
opposed to external geometry. So that's another yet another
idea of the multiverse is that to try to explain
why we're in one particular type of universe. But
there's all these other possibilities out there, 10 to
the 500 other possibilities out there, which is very
, very perplexing. And that's how dimensions comes into
the picture of the multiverse models. And so these
universes with different configurations. WW should we expect them
to also have different laws of physics? Yes.
So they would have uh not necessarily uh super different
laws like you might like, you might think if
you know naively physics, you say, OK,
force equals mass times acceleration, something you learn in
basic physics. And then, you know, you
wouldn't have like force is mass to the third power
at times acceleration hub, but you might have uh
different constants strength constants for the forces. So we
have all these parameters in physics which tell you how
strong, how strongly particles can interact with each other
. So for example, uh if you have,
you know, two magnets like two refrigerator magnets or
bar magnets, and you hold them 1 m away
from each other, you know how strong the attraction
will be. Well, maybe in another universe,
they would have a much stronger attraction to each other
. Maybe in a third universe, they have a
much weaker attraction to each other. So, in
one universe, like, you might have a refrigerator
and you wanna put a magnet on the refrigerator,
you know, with your favorite football team or something
like that, you put it on the refrigerator and
it just never sticks because the magnets are never strong
enough. And then another universe, you get,
um, a magnet for your favorite football team.
You put on a refrigerator and then that football team
does terribly like they keep, you know, uh
losing like, oh, I, I'm gonna support
another football team. You try to take the first
magnet off, but it's impossible because it's stuck on
there forever because the magnetism is so strong. So
, you know, we're lucky, we're in a
universe where you can take refrigerator magnets on and off
and they'll stick as long as you want to.
But then if you wanna take them off, you
can take them off. But let me just ask
you 11 more question about uh dimension. So,
is it possible in any way to, I mean
, to test that out empirically, to detect them
empirically or, or is this something that we just
are able to figure out mathematically well with these unseen
dimensions? Um The whole theory is designed so that
these dimensions would be undetectable. But then of course
, people will say, well, then how do
you prove it? Well, then you try to
look for what's called, what are called low energy
ramifications So string theory operates, it lives on a
very, very high energy scale. So um if
you um if, if you want to see string
theory, you know, don't know, don't really
uh have the possibility of creating uh colliders on earth
or even in the solar system that would be strong
enough to produce those ultra high energies. But then
people say, well, maybe you can see a
slight change in the results due to the higher dimensions
. So there are theories that predict you would see
a slight difference in the outcome of a collision experiment
due to the fact that there are more dimensions in
space. So those are the things people are trying
to test for these subtle differences. And so far
, these haven't been found. Um that would be
Nobel Prize winning material. If you could show that
a collision experiment, you get a difference that's significant
enough to show that some of the energy, for
example, escaped into a higher dimension. And when
it comes to the origins of our own universe and
the Big Bang, which is something you referred to
earlier. I mean, what is the most accepted
uh explanation for the origins of our universe or the
way that the Big Bang occurred or played out?
So, um physicists, most physicists don't talk about
what happens before the Big Bang because um as people
like Stephen Hawking proved in the 19 sixties, the
actual Big Bang event would be a singularity So nothing
would be detective before then. Now that said there
are other theories about cosmic cycles that there were other
cycles of creation. But the standard Big Bang theory
is that it's a singularity that time began essentially at
that point. So we can't really talk about before
the Big Bang. And then space came into existence
during the time of the Big Bang time came to
existence and then the universe immediately began expanding. But
then um at this point, there was a certain
amount of energy in the universe, a certain amount
of energy background. And one thing um that was
found in the early universe is something with a technical
name. It's called a scalar field. And a
scalar field sounds like, you know, something very
mathematical. But in reality, it just means that
you have a map of energy that's different from point
to point. Kind of like if you were going
mountain climbing and you wanted to find out which were
the highest peaks which were the lowest peaks. And
what would be the best way to climb up a
mountain? You might have a topographical map and that
topographical map would tell you the elevation at every point
. So it might say, OK, this point
is 500 m high. This point is 1000 m
high. This point is more, this point is
less and then you can plan your walk and your
hike um up the mountain based on the topographical map
. Well, if you look at the early universe
right after the Big Bang, you could map out
its energy and that would give you what we call
a scalar field. And if that energy has a
certain profile, meaning it has a certain level,
um and that level persists for a while and slowly
changes over time, then that, that bump in
energy um causes expansion super rapid expansion at that particular
point in space. So if you have a certain
energy profile, that's, that's flat for a certain
period of time, meaning it would be kind of
like you have, you know, uh you climb
up a mountain and then you have this flat plateau
where things are pretty much level that triggers the universe
space in the universe to start expanding really rapidly.
It's just a result of Einstein's general theory of relativity
which says that space expands depending upon what's in it
, what mass is in it, what energy is
in it. So space starts to expand rapidly that
stretches out that part of the universe and that's called
inflation and that happens super rapidly. And suddenly when
um when things uh expand enough, um the universe
no longer um sits in that energy zone that,
that it it it's no longer subject to that scalar
energy field um which, which has evolved slowly over
time. Um And that you no longer have inflationary
period, that enormous amount of energy created by that
super rapid expansion turns into all these particles. So
all the particles that we see today, you know
, light particles called photons, the particles we know
as electrons the quarks. And this whole zoo of
particles is created at the exact moment that inflation stops
. And all this energy turns into matter. Uh
following E equals MC squared energy is matter times the
speed of light squared as Einstein said, so then
that's when the the physical universe with all of the
particles is created. But as Andre Linde said,
um this might happen in other parts of the early
cosmos creating other inflationary events and other universes. And
that's where you get the multiverse picture. Mhm So
I I mean, is that idea that we sometimes
see or read about in popular science publications uh where
I mean, if a uni if a multiverse is
real, it is usually depicted visually as different uh
bubbles or different spheres. And then uh we read
that uh basically what could have happened is that two
of them or perhaps even more collide with and when
they collide they create a new universe or they provoke
what would be a big bang? And the a
new universe uh is created from that, I mean
, does that have uh any support in actual physics
or not? Well, there are ideas of higher
dimensional planes called membranes or brains for short colliding along
a higher dimension. That's a different idea that was
proposed by Neil Turret Paul Steinhardt and others uh around
uh 2000. And uh that's called a cyclic cosmology
. And that's an alternative to inflation and inflation,
the bubbles expand and they could collide. But when
they collide, they don't really create a new universe
, they create, maybe create a little scar.
So when two universes collide, they might create some
disruption in matter and energy and that theoretically could be
seen in a uh kind of rings scar like rings
in the cosmic microwave background. And scientists are trying
to look for these rings that are relics of early
collisions between us and another universe. So that is
one way of trying to uh physically prove the existence
of a multiverse. So um in, in my
book, I talked interviewed Jana P Pols who's uh
who's a researcher at the University of London, who
uh her team is trying to look for uh evidence
of of bubble collisions in the early universe. And
also their latest project is to try to simulate this
computationally and do black holes connect in any way to
the multiverse or not? Well, there is a
theory um by Lise Mullen, uh a physicist that
um black holes uh they, they, they are
known to be extreme events in the universe. And
um I if you look at um uh standard general
relativity, we say that the more mass you have
concentrated in a point, the more space time warps
. Well, for black holes, you have an
infinite warping. So it creates what can look like
a tear or a hole in the fabric of space
time. And um there are ways to mathematically connect
the black hole with another part of space and create
a kind of a um you know, what could
be a connection with another part of our universe.
And some speculate that it could create a new universe
uh like uh as Lise Mullen called it a baby
universe and that this baby universe could grow up into
a big universe and then create more black holes.
And he has this idea of survival of the fittest
where the universe that creates the most black holes is
evolutionary fitter than other universes because uh it also creates
um more stars and more planets and more, more
likelihood for life. So that's a really interesting idea
, but that's not really the thrust of uh most
researchers who do, who study the multiverse as more
of an idea of, of one researcher and does
the science and philosophy of counter factuals uh have anything
to do with the idea of a multiverse. Well
, yes. Uh So in philosophy, we can
speculate upon all the possibilities that are out there.
And uh that was, you know, done all
the way back to people like philosophers like Leibnitz.
So Leibnitz talked about all the possible universes out there
that he, he talked about the divine or God
thinking about all these other possibilities. But of course
, God is uh as, as he would say
, perfect in his wisdom and chose from all these
among these other possibilities, the best possibility for us
, the best of all possible worlds. But he
imagined all these other worlds out there, you know
, where earth was brutally hot and unpleasant and you
know, food was unappetizing and people were, you
know, uh you know, these unthinking beings.
But in his wisdom, he said, OK,
we want a world which is pleasant, as nice
climate, as nice oceans. And as people who
are kind of a little bit like, you know
, a little bit like the divine because they can
make choices and so forth. So Leibniz kind of
talked about this idea of the best of all possible
worlds. And the writer, uh Voltaire famously satirized
this idea with his character Candide. Uh So as
this novel Candide, where he had a character named
Pangloss who was a philosopher who would no matter what
happened, there could be an earthquake. Um In
fact, I think he talked about the, the
great earthquake in Lisbon and uh you know, it's
horrible earthquake. And he said, well, you
know, it must be the best possibility because God
meant us to be in the best of all possible
worlds. So even if, even if you know
where there's all this suffering, it still works out
for the best. And uh Voltaire thought that was
very amusing that a philosopher would say anything is,
is always the best outcome. Mhm So one of
the questions that you also explore in the book is
how explaining why the universe is habitable uh uh as
something to do with the idea of the multiverse.
So what's the connection there or the possible connection?
Well, this was an idea called the Anthropic Principle
developed by Brandon Carter who was someone who was at
Cambridge. He, he was a friend of Stephen
Hawking. And uh you know, Cambridge was this
really hot area for cosmology. It still is.
But in the 19 seventies, uh Cambridge and Princeton
were two of the best places to go in Princeton
. You had uh John Wheeler in Cambridge, you
had people like Hawking and Penrose and Brandon Carter was
also there. And Carter also spent some time at
Princeton. So we got to know John Wheeler and
he found out about Hugh Everett's uh idea of the
many worlds interpretation. So that got Brandon Carter thinking
about the multiverse, although it wasn't called as such
. And he thought, well, there's all these
questions, cosmology about uh parameters like why certain physical
parameters should have certain values. And that's called the
fine tuning problem. Because if the strength of electromagnetism
was different, you wouldn't have uh you know,
for example, atoms, you know, being stable
. If you had, for example, the charge
of a proton being slightly different than a charge of
electron, then you know, the atoms would collapse
. So there are all these coincidences in the universe
, things that um if you change slightly, the
universe would not be suitable for life. And Brendan
Carter said, hey, wait a minute, what
if there's all these other units versus out there where
things are different? But the fact that our universe
eventually leads to stable planets, um thriving stars and
um life and, and particularly intelligent life that can
talk about the universe. Uh Maybe that restricts this
range of possibilities down to one universe. And they
call that the anthropic principle for the Latin anthroposophy and
some others said, well, maybe that term is
a little bit misleading because you don't just need people
, you just need stability, stable, stable planets
and life. Um You could have other beings um
observe it. But um but anyway, that's uh
one idea of the multiverse is uh this idea of
the anthropic principle and it explains why um you have
a universe that supports habitable worlds and does the idea
of the multiverse connect in any way to a potential
theory of everything or a simple unified explanation of the
natural forces. Well, um this is what we
call the holy grail of physics or the ultimate goal
of physics is to create a theory that unites all
of the natural forces into a single simple set of
equations. And uh it's an elusive goal because um
we made great progress in uh the 19 sixties and
19 seventies with developing the Standard Model and the standard
model includes the electro weak unification, which very,
very nicely unites electromagnetism with the weak force. The
weak force is the force that explains radioactivity. And
of course, electromagnetism explains why charges uh attract to
repel and why magnets attract to repel. All of
those can be explained with a single theory that is
also uh consistent with quantum physics and it's very,
very accurate. So electro weak uh predictions are as
accurate as any experiment that's been ever been done.
So it's extremely successful. Now, we also have
the strong nuclear force which explains why atomic nuclei are
stable. And there's a theory for that called quantum
chromodynamics, which is a very, very successful theory
. Um And um it's not as well tested,
I should say as electro weak, but it also
has very similar properties to electro week and involves this
idea of uh two types of, of entities.
One is the matter particles quarks, electrons and so
forth. And then you have force carrying particles which
are particles that are um conveyed from one particle ma
matter particle to another. So they're exchanged just like
throwing a ball to matter particles, throw in a
sense, a force uh carrier back and forth and
that creates a force. So you have uh a
, a bunch of force carriers, you have photons
which carry electromagnetic force, you have the WW particle
and Z particles which carry the weak force and you
have gluons which carry the strong force. Now,
in principle, we should have gravity should be described
using a force carrying particle which some people have called
graviton. But no one has successfully developed a quantum
theory of gravitation that is uh testable and describes,
you know what we measure in the universe. There
are a lot of ideas out there for quantum gravitation
and then the theory of everything would describe quantum gravity
in a way that's consistent with all the other forces
and unify all those into a quantum theory of all
particles and all forces. And the leading candidate for
that is string theory. But as I mentioned,
uh string theory has all these possibilities, 10 to
the 500 string uh geometries. And each of those
creates its own uh theory of physics of and leads
to a diff different parameters for the Standard model.
So those need to be significantly narrowed down to create
a theory of everything where the multiverse comes into play
is you can say, OK, there's all these
possibilities out there, there's all these theories out there
. But the theory of everything that happens to correspond
to our universe was narrowed down by the fact that
we are here using the anthropic principle, we can
say, well, there are many, many,
many, many different theories of everything, but there's
one that matches a universe that creates planets that creates
stars, creates intelligent life. And that's our particular
theory of everything. And that's you know why we
have these particular parameters, different strengths of different constants
. And that in, in, in theory,
narrows everything down to one universe and explains why we
are living in this one universe and explains, you
know, all the constants for our universe. Well
, we're very, very far from that. That's
kind of an idealization. That's the goal, but
no one has ever come up with a way to
narrow everything down to one possibility. But what are
perhaps the main difficulties with integrating gravity with quantum physics
? What are the bigger obstacles there? Well,
the biggest obstacle is mathematical um so back in the
19 forties, um physicists such as Richard Feynman,
Julian Schwinger and Si Tiro Tomonaga in Japan developed what
are called uh renormalization methods in quantum electrodynamics. Now
that is a very technical term, but basically what
that means is that you can take two electrons which
are char basic charge particles. And you say,
OK, let's develop a quantum theory of how these
electrons interact with each other. And the way they
interact with each other is by exchanging a light particle
called a photon. And then you say, OK
, you have an electron gives off a photon,
that photon is absorbed by another electron. And then
that electron acquires a certain amount of energy acquires a
certain amount of momentum. And then you could predict
the ways where the electron will end up. And
that's called scattering scattering is when you have two particles
, you predict, you know where they end up
what angles, what's the probability they'll end up at
certain angles. And that's something you can physically measure
the scattering, you physically measure where these particles end
up. You test test it according to theory.
And in the 19 forties, quantum electrodynamics showed how
you can add up all the possible ways electrons interact
and using something called Feynman diagrams, which is a
neat way of adding up all the possibilities. And
then using mathematical methods, get rid of infinite terms
that pop up. So if you do these calculations
with particles, because particles are infinitesimal, they really
elementary particles are not only tiny, but they're believed
in this theory to be, you know, mathematically
have zero size. So if you put that into
the theory, you get infinite terms because one divided
by zero is infinity um or unlimited. So what
during these calculations before a five inch ring or Toman
NAA, they found these infinite terms, but they
were able to use a method called renormalization which basically
matches terms, subtracts them so that you get rid
of all the infinite terms. And that's renormalization.
And when electro the weak theory was developed in 19
sixties and 19 seventies, it was shown that you
could also match up terms, subtract them out and
then get um get uh a a finite amount.
And I use a nice analogy in my book about
um how renormalization works? I imagine a couple two
people and they're living together and one of them earns
money and every week gets a paycheck and she adds
up all the money she earns o throughout a lifetime
. And she imagines that she, she lives indefinitely
. Um It's just a hypothetical. So would make
an infinite amount of money. And the other person
is spending each, each month and the spending would
be infinite. And if you say, hey,
wait a minute, this doesn't add up in the
bookkeeping infinite income, but an infinite amount of spending
, that doesn't make any sense. But if you
say, OK, every month, one person brings
in the paycheck, the other person spends it and
that creates a finite amount each month. So that
so therefore everything matches up in the in the bookkeeping
. So the accounting works out similarly, you can
do in a kind of accounting in particle physics with
electromagnetism and the weak force in which everything gives you
a finite result. Well, it turns out with
gravity, you try to do this and you don't
get, you can't match up the terms you keep
getting infinite answers. And the only way around it
as far as physicists can tell is to say,
there's no such thing as infinite decimal that every particle
must have a finite size. And that leads to
the idea of finite strands which are known as strings
at that vibrate instead of particles. So that leads
to string theory. And string theory is finite So
you don't get infinite number of uh you know,
get infinite terms. But then um you have all
these possibilities for string theory. So you have to
narrow things down. So that's the problem with string
theory of so many options. So earlier, I've
asked you about the Big Bang and the origins of
our universe. But how about the future of our
universe? What are perhaps the main hypothesis that physicists
have proposed for the future of our universe? And
is it that one of them has more support than
the others? I mean, basically, what do
we know at this point about the possible future of
our universe? Well, until the 19 nineties,
um you know, I should say between the 19
, late, late 19 twenties or 19 thirties and
19 nineties, the basic idea was that the universe
had three options. One of them is that expands
and then um eventually collapses. And then the second
possibility is that expands and the expansion slows down but
slows down very gradually. And the expansion keeps going
. And the third option was kind of in between
the two that the universe al almost collapses, not
quite collapses and keeps slowing down and slowing down,
but never quite collapses. But then in 1998 these
two teams of astronomers discovered using measurements of exploding stars
or supernova that the universe is speeding up in its
expansion. And that's called cosmic acceleration. And that
means that you have 1/4 option, which is that
the universe will keep expanding forever, but not only
that, but will speed up in its expansion.
And eventually just everything will just keep getting more and
more dilute and that Galaxies will get further and further
apart. And then finally, our set of Galaxies
will be a hermit, meaning like a loner in
, in the universe and we won't even see any
other Galaxies, we'll only see our galaxy and maybe
a few others in the vicinity. And uh that
is called the sometimes called a big whimper scenario uh
from the Ts Elliot Poe poem. Um that you
know how's the world ends? Not with a bang
, but with a whimper. Um it's a line
from Matthias Elliott poem. But um there's an even
scarier uh possibility called The Big Rip. And that
is that um whatever is, is causing acceleration keeps
getting stronger and stronger. And then eventually everything is
ripped apart, including planets are torn apart, stars
are torn apart and even the atoms in people's bodies
are torn apart. So everything is torn to shreds
and that will be the end of the universe.
Now, those are some possibilities in the standard model
of, of cosmology. But then if you believe
in cyclic universes, I believe in, um for
example, the idea of Steinhardt and Turek that the
universe is um uh cyclical because you have uh two
membranes also known as brains colliding with each other periodically
and clashing with each other. Um There would be
a periodic phase in which these two like, it's
like hyper planes or planes in a higher dimension,
collide with each other, wipe everything out and reset
the universe. And that would be um the end
of everything, but that would start a new phase
of the universe. And then finally, there's Roger
Penrose idea, a different kind of cycle where at
the end of the universe, there's emptiness, everything
becomes more and more dilute all the particles uh evaporate
. And then eventually you have sheer emptiness, but
that emptiness um has a kind of identity crisis and
it mathematically and instead of thinking of itself is very
large, it thinks of itself as very small and
there's just mathematical transition and then creates a new phase
of the universe. So you have a new cycle
. So those are some of the ideas about the
end of time and you know, either destruction and
recreation of the universe or just the destruction of the
universe. And is there or I I mean,
what is the likelihood that whatever kind of scenario will
occur and the universe will still be able to sustain
life and perhaps even worse uh being able to sustain
intelligent life like us? Well, so, so
we, we believe in, in, you know
, the current standard cosmology that the universe is expanding
faster and faster. And that um but also that
something called entropy, which is a measure of disorderly
energy is increasing. And that means that stars will
eventually burn out and the sun will eventually die if
the sun dies. We imagine that maybe we have
spaceships that take us to another star, but then
that star might die. So then we go to
a third star and we keep going and uh maybe
all the stars in our galaxy die. And maybe
we have, you know, uh not only interstellar
travel but intergalactic travel, we try another galaxy,
but eventually all of these Galaxies stars will either um
you know, become uh so cold, they,
they can't support life or turn into black holes and
so forth. So then the question is, can
intelligent life survive? And that was answered um at
one point by Roger Penrose who speculated that maybe we
will develop ways to transform our uh intelligence, our
consciousness into maybe, um you know, artificial intelligence
or robots and that could live in under very,
very cold circumstances. But I'm not sure if that
would be quite as satisfying to say that life would
be in these robots that, you know, exist
in, in, in ultra cold temperatures. It's
not the kind of life that we, that most
people would want to live. Yeah, for sure
. And uh if a multiverse is real, would
it have any bearing on the future of our own
universe? Uh Well, we, if the multiverse
, the cosmological multiverse is real, um unless uh
there's some collision with another universe that happens to hit
our part of the observable universe, probably it wouldn't
affect us very much. We would just know that
there are other universes out there that might have different
fates than our universe. Uh So, uh might
not, might not affect us very much. Um
in terms of the quantum multiverse of the many worlds
possibility, um It's possible that we would have other
versions of ourselves that might have slightly different um fates
in life. Um You know, if let's say
during a quantum event uh that somehow affected um the
rest of our lives, it's unlikely that um an
obs a single quantum observation will make a big difference
in our lives. But it's hypothetically possible that by
making a different observation that that could affect our lives
and steer our lives on a different course. And
so, of course, in science fiction, many
times, people use the idea of time traveling and
depict it in different ways in movies, books,
et cetera. But is there, is it theoretically
possible according to physics for time traveling to exist or
occur? And if so, would it connect in
any way to the idea of the multiverse or not
? Well, when we talk about time travel,
we need to distinguish between time travel into the future
and time travel into the past. Well as Einstein
uh showed in his, in his special theory of
relativity, if you take an astronaut launch the astronaut
to space and that astronaut somehow can travel very,
very close to the speed of light. And that
astronaut returns to earth, that astronaut's clock would tick
more slowly than earth clocks. And that astronaut could
theoretically travel into the future of earth. Um So
, for example, uh if that astronaut was traveling
99.99% the speed of light, they might come back
and see that all of their relatives are either,
you know, 100 years old or, or likely
deceased. Um, you know, and uh Earth
is, you know, instead of being the 21st
century and the 22nd century, um because time is
relative. So that is a relatively simple way to
time travel. And that create doesn't create any contradictions
because you would just go into the future, you
would arrive in the future and you would maybe have
different customs and, you know, you would say
, where, where are the smartphones and say,
no, we use brain chips now or we use
something else. So you would say, ok,
technology has advanced. So that would be one way
of time travel. But what about traveling to the
past? We imagine going back in time and trying
to prevent the Second World War or something like that
, you know, you know, all these tr
tragedies. Um Well, physics does have the possibility
of that by creating something called a wormhole. Now
, a wormhole traversable wormhole is a little bit like
a black hole only it's stabilized. So instead of
having this um very narrow uh tunnel that possibly connects
to another region of space that would not be uh
you cannot travel into which will be deadly. Um
We imagine being able to stabilize this tunnel and make
it so that you can travel through it and end
up in a different part of space. Well as
uh Kip Thorne and some of his students showed,
uh there's a way that you can uh manipulate the
wormhole so that they can act as a time machine
and you could travel backward in time. And um
and then uh you wouldn't be able to travel before
the creation of the wormhole, but you could travel
back to at least the time when the wormhole was
created. And uh so if there are wormholes that
were created naturally in space that were useful as time
machines, you could use one of those. And
then the question is, could you affect history?
And the way it connects with the multiverse is in
science fiction, particularly, there's this idea that maybe
if you go backward in time and you try to
change history that maybe you start a new branch of
reality. So for example, let's say you go
back in time to the age of Hitler and you
assassinate Hitler and there's no Hitler, there's no Nazi
Germany and World War Two doesn't happen, but maybe
something else happens, maybe Stalin becomes all powerful and
takes over Europe. And then, um so now
we have, instead of, you know, Nazis
trying to take over Europe that's run by Stalin and
the Soviets. OK. So that's a different branch
of reality, maybe that would represent, you know
, a type of multiverse where you have all these
other alternative histories. But that is very science fiction
, a very speculative. It's not something that physics
can prove. So another thing that perhaps is also
speculative you, you tell me is the simulation hypothesis
. So what is it? And does it also
, does it have any relationship to the multiverse?
Well, um the simulation hypothesis is the idea that
could it be possible that everything we see, everything
we observe is a computer simulation that was designed by
some other intelligent being. And the argument for that
is imagine our civilization, um our own civilization evolves
naturally. And currently we have some forms of artificial
intelligence like we could create, you know, at
this point in time, you can create an essay
that looks like it was written by a human being
. It might have some mistakes, you know,
using chat G BT or some other mechanism. Well
, imagine um that you could uh create a simulated
human being, you know, something that would be
indistinguishable by from a human being. And then you
go on to create a simulated city where you have
human beings interact and it seems like human beings and
then you create a simulated planet and then maybe a
simulated, you know, solar system simulated galaxy.
Well, if intelligence intelligent beings uh last long enough
, the chances according to some thinkers that they could
create a simulation is 100% that eventually they would develop
the technology for this. So then imagine you have
all these uh natural worlds out there that create simulation
. So you would have all these simulated worlds out
there. Eventually, the simulated worlds would greatly outnumber
the natural worlds because you could have one natural world
creating all these simulated worlds. So then you estimate
the chances that we're in a simulated world or a
natural world and that becomes almost 100% according to these
thinkers that were in a simulated world, not a
natural world. So I don't quite buy that idea
personally. Um because, you know, there's,
there's all these other arguments about design that were designed
and uh the simplest one that, you know,
people who are religious believe or may some people religious
believe? Well, we were designed by a divine
being. Ok. Well, some people don't believe
that some people do believe that, but it's a
simpler belief to say that there's a divine being out
there than to say, oh, well, there's
another, you know, set of beings that created
us well, who created them, you know,
were they as simulation? And it gets into this
whole uh philosophical uh tangled argument about, you know
, why are there real beings? Why are they
simulated beings? And what's the connection? And if
we actually were living in a simulation, would there
be any way at all of verifying that of empirically
? I mean, being sure of that. Well
, I can only turn to science fiction and say
, well, maybe someone would hand us a red
pill and you take it and all of a sudden
you see, you see everything like in the matrix
. Um because um you know, if it was
, it was a really smart intelligent being, they
would create a perfect simulation. So um but uh
you could speculate about intelligent being that's very, very
, very smart but makes mistakes and creates a flawed
simulation. So all of a sudden you wake up
and you look up at the sky and instead of
seeing, seeing the moon or whatever, you know
, wake up at night and instead of seeing the
moon, you see something that looks like pixels and
you're like, wait a minute, what are those
pixels doing there? But you know, if,
if an intelligent race was smart enough to develop a
simulation, it would, it would conceivably be a
perfect simulation, then you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference. So this becomes almost like, you
know, in a way, I think it gets
a little silly uh a little comical like, OK
, you know, if it's a perfect simulation,
could there be flaws? OK, that's gets a
little bit silly to think about things like that.
So we've been touching on science fiction here and there
during our conversation. But what are probably some of
the most common ways that in popular culture, people
portray the multiverse and as a physicist, I mean
, is it that you just take it lightly?
I mean, it's just fiction, whatever or,
uh is it that some of those ways that the
multiverse is portrayed actually bother you? Well, I
think of it from the point of view of somebody
who's a researcher and they apply to the government for
a grant or they applied to a corporation for a
grant. So let's say they have this idea for
testing, you know, using observations of the cosmic
micro background to test for other universes and the word
multiverse comes up and they send it to, um
, somebody to review their grants and that person has
just seen a marvel movie they see, just saw
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and they come
back and say this is not real science. This
is science fiction. You don't get any money from
me or it's another possibility. You could have someone
who says, wow, I love that movie.
I love science fiction. You know, that's really
cool that you can test these things in real life
. You get, you know, here's$100,000 you
know, for your grant,100,000. So then
, um then you could be lucky. So it's
, it's a little bit of a mixed thing.
Some scientists are like, well, science fiction talks
about multiverse ideas, those are really not real science
. So let's not even talk about a multiverse and
others uh appreciate the popular interest as a way of
supporting science. Like, OK, you've learned,
you've seen the Multiverse in movies, let me show
you the real multiverse ideas. Forget about the movies
. Here's the real science of it. So in
the movies, the main attraction is the idea of
, of what if you know, what if you
know Spiderman came from a different background? What if
you know in Star Trek instead of Spock being logical
and emotionless? What if Spock were evil and very
emotional? So we see, you know, an
alternate universe where Spock as a beard and is sinister
and so forth. So these are all talked about
in, um, you know, in science fiction
. And then there's even the simple question, what
if I missed a train instead of making a train
? And that's the movie sliding doors where a woman
just misses a subway train versus just makes a subway
train? And the movie shows what happens to her
life in the, the world where she just makes
the train and now their possibility where she just misses
the train. And in one of them, she
discovers that her boyfriend is having an affair with another
woman and she breaks up with the boyfriend, she
finds another boyfriend who's much nicer and her life continues
and then in the other scenario, she doesn't discover
that her boyfriend is cheating on her, she continues
with the same boyfriend and then we see what happens
at the end and I'm not gonna give too much
away, but the branch of reality, which looks
like a good one might not be so good after
all in the movie. So, these are intriguing
ways to think about the multiverse in science fiction.
Uh, I mean, it's as if, uh
, every time in movies, every time people think
about different possibilities, they're dealing with counterfactual in their
mind. What if this happened? What if that
happened? Reality branched and then a new universe popped
up where the, what if really happened? Right
. Yes, that's right. So we, we
often imagine, uh, what happened, what would
happen if we made different decisions in our lives?
Like what if we decided to move to a different
city? So, um, you know, what
if we decided a different job? So, so
imagine we grew up and as a teenager, we
were in a rock band and, you know,
we played it at our high school and everybody applauded
and then our parents say, wait a minute,
you can't make any money from a rock rock music
. You should go into a serious job and we
become an accountant instead. But then, um,
we imagine what would be a scenario where we say
to our parents. No, no, no.
We wanted to stay in music and then we become
The Beatles or The Rolling Stones or, you know
, they're very successful rock band. We say,
ah, it's very good that we didn't listen to
our parents. And we, we pursued our musical
dream because we became one of the most successful bands
of all time. So we don't know until,
unless there were, uh, you know, the
possibility of viewing other universes, other branches of reality
, we wouldn't know if our decisions were good decisions
or bad decisions. So one last question and then
sort of related to this previous one. Do you
see, I, I mean, how do you
look at the popular ideas that people have about the
universe? Do you think that they attribute specific meanings
to the universe to the multiverse that the it might
be meaningful in some way for people to consider the
possibility of a multiverse existing? Well, I think
it's, it's fun to imagine about different things.
And I like science fiction personally and I like dreaming
about other worlds and thinking about different scenarios and I
think that's, that's perfectly healthy. Uh The only
time I have a bit of an objection is when
people exploit quantum physics or exploit the idea of a
multiverse and try to convince people that um they can
control their own reality by using quantum physics. So
they say they'll say something like, like all you
have to do is want to be rich and you
know, um you know, buy my book or
listen to my audio. I'll show you how,
so it's only$100 for this audio. And you'll
learn how that using quantum physics, you'll uh use
your mind and make the right choice and that will
you into a universe where you're very wealthy using,
you know, the idea of a multiverse. Well
, somebody is making money from a false premise there
but it's very easy to try to exploit physics and
to try to convince people uh that they can use
it to become rich or become, you know,
immortal, become, you know, super healthy and
so forth. So I would steer personally, I
would steer away from those ideas because it's, it's
not really a proper use of a physics to say
if you think you're rich, you're gonna be rich
. It's like that very popular book from a few
years ago. The Secret, right? And other
similar ideas popularized by some self help gurus, right
? Yes. Although there are people who, who
find quantum books in the self help section of a
bookstore and then become seriously interested in real scientific ideas
. Like for example, um uh I, I
know a rock musician who in the 19 nineties looked
at a lot of self help books and that led
him to write songs about quantum physics. So it
can be a good thing. Well, let's send
on that note then and the book is again the
lure of the multiverse extra dimensions, other worlds and
parallel universes. I'm leaving a link to it in
the description of the interview. And uh Paul just
before we go apart from the book, would you
like, would you like to let people know where
they can find you when your work on the internet
? Well, I'm active on what used to be
known as Twitter, also known as X. I'm
also on uh Blue Sky Mastodon. I have my
own uh blog. Uh Yeah, it's active sometimes
I post things and I post articles. Uh So
if you Google my name, uh some of these
things should come up, you know, social media
, there's a Facebook writing page for me, but
I'm not uh involved in that, but there are
a lot of social media that you can reach out
to me and especially on um X Twitter. I'm
, I'm very active on that under the hand of
P Halpern. Great. So I'm also leaving that
in the description of the interview and thank you so
much again for taking the time to come on the
show. It's been fun to talk with you.
Thank you, Ricardo. Those are wonderful questions and
I really enjoyed the interview. Hi guys. Thank
you for watching this interview. Until the end.
If you liked it, please share it. Leave
a like and hit the subscription button. The show
is brought to you by the N Lights learning and
development. Then differently check the website at N lights.com
. And also please consider supporting the show on Patreon
or paypal. I would also like to give a
huge thank you to my main patrons and paypal supporters
, Perera Larson Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno, Bernard
Seche O of Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whitten Bear
. No wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Condors,
Philip Forrest Connolly. Then the Met Robert Wine in
NAI Z Mark Nevs called in Holbrook Field, Governor
Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferus and H
Her Me and Lain Jung Y and the K Hes
Mark Smith J Tom Hummel S Friends, David Sloan
Wilson. Ya dear, Ro Ro Die Jan Punter
Romani Charlotte, Bli Nicole Barba, Adam Hunt,
Pavlo Stassi na me, Gary G Alman Sam of
Zed YPJ Barboa, Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden
Broner Douglas Fry Franca Beto Lati Cortez or Solis Scott
Zachary FTD and W Daniel Friedman, William Buckner,
Paul. Giorgio, Luke Loki, Georgio Theophano,
Chris Williams and Peter Wo David Williams Di Costa Anton
Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie Martinez,
Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey Junior, Old Ebon
, Starry Michael Bailey. Then spur by Robert Grassy
Zorn, Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radick,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson, Chris Tory
Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica. No Week,
Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley Man,
George Katis Valentine Steinman, Perras, Kate Van Goler
, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular
Jer Urla. Good enough Gregory Hastings David Pins of
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos Net. A
special thanks to my producers is our web, Jim
Frank Luca Stein, Tom Veg and Bernard N Cortes
Dixon, Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick
Tobin, John Carl, Negro, Nick Ortiz and
Nick Golden. And to my executive producers, Matthew
Lavender, Si Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie. Thank
you for all.